every year every federal employee has to
have it's mandatory by government
whistleblower training every single year
and Insider threat training every single
year
and my whole time in in the FBI they
were always separate this year we found
out because thankfully there are still
some good people in the FBI uh that that
training was merged into one so the FBI
didn't even they didn't even say you
know whistleblowing is good and you can
do it like they used to they used to say
yeah it's protected uh now they combine
those trainings overtly saying
whistleblowers are Insider threats I
mean that was the takeaway from the
people we know in the agency who took
that training that slide deck was
released to the public so we can go see
it it's online and it's like okay so the
FBI is not even trying to hide the fact
that they will retaliate against you